- Hi, I'm Meaghan, and in this video,
we'll walk through setting
up a class on Khan Academy.
First, log in to Khan Academy.
Once you're logged in,
you should land on the teacher dashboard.
The teacher dashboard
is the starting point
for most teacher-focused
activities on Khan Academy
including creating and organizing classes.
From the teacher dashboard,
make sure you are on the classes tab
and then click the add new class button
in the top right corner of the screen.
We recommend that you
create separate classes
for each group of students you teach.
For example, if you teach four sections
of seventh grade math,
we recommend you create a
separate class for each section.
If you already use Google Classroom,
you can import your
classes with all students
directly to Khan Academy.
If this is not the case, start
by giving your class a name.
A tip we hear from teachers
is to choose a naming system
that helps keep your
teacher dashboard organized
and easy to find for both
you and your students.
A common trend is to use your name,
class period and subject.
Now let's choose one or
more courses for your class.
You can scroll down
to see the full list of courses available.
You can choose the course by subject
such as Algebra I or US History
or you can choose the
course by grade level
like second grade reading or
get ready for fifth grade math.
And don't worry, if you change your mind,
you can edit your class
name and courses at any time
in the class settings.
After you've set up a class,
you'll want to add students
and there's three different
ways you can do this.
The first option is to
use Google Classroom.
If you're a teacher who
uses Google Classroom,
you can link your Google Classroom
and Khan Academy accounts
to import your class roster directly.
This will automatically
send emails to your students
letting them know they've
been added to your class.
The second option is for
students to join your class
using the class code.
Each class created on Khan
Academy has a unique code
which students can use to join your class.
Students only need to
enter this code one time
to be connected to your class.
You can share the code
with students via email
or by displaying the
code in your classroom.
Students can enter the
code from the teachers tab
on their learner home.
They will be automatically
added to your class roster
after they enter the code.
Some teachers find the
process of adding students
by class code challenging
especially those with younger students.
But don't worry, we have one more option.
The third option for adding students
is to create accounts for them.
Please remember before
creating accounts for students
in the United States,
Khan Academy assumes that
you already have permission
from parents or guardians of
students under the age of 13.
We do not recommend this option
for students over the age of 13
as it creates a more
restrictive type of account.
Select the option create
your student account.
When you create these accounts,
Khan Academy automatically generates
usernames and passwords.
You are able to create the
passwords for your students
according to preference
and we strongly recommend
you download the complete
list with login information
to keep in your files
in case you need to
consult them in the future.
One important warning.
You will only be able
to download this list
when you create accounts.
You will receive an email with
all this information as well,
but you will not be able to retrieve
or edit this information
including passwords at any other time.
Now you've set up a
class and added students.
But what happens when
the class roster changes?
We know students move in and
out of classes during the year.
To keep your student list up to date,
select the class from
the teacher dashboard
and in the left side navigation,
select the students tab.
From there, you will be able
to add or remove students
from your classes.
If a new student is joining your class,
click add new students and
choose your preferred method
to add the student from the three methods
shared earlier in this video.
If one of your students moves
from one class to another
but remains your student,
select that student's name
from their current class
and click on the add to class option.
From here, select the class
the student is joining
to add them to a new class.
Once that is complete,
remove the student from the original class
using the remove from class option.
In this situation, you
can move the student
from one class to the other
without the student needing
to take any additional action.
If you are no longer a student's teacher,
select the student's name
and click stop teaching.
This will remove the student
from all of your class lists
and disconnect the student's account
from your teacher account.
You will no longer have access
to any of this student's information.
If you want to clear
an entire class roster
like you might wanna do at
the end of a school year,
select the box in the first row
and then click stop teaching.
This will remove all the
students in that class.
Many teachers recommend
doing this over the summer
in an effort to clean up your
Khan Academy teacher account
and prevent the accumulation
of students year over year.
One other rostering tip we'd
like to share with you all.
Khan Academy student rosters
are automatically alphabetized,
but student display names
often appear as their usernames
rather than their real names.
As a teacher, you can edit the
display name of any student
by hovering over the
name you want to change
and clicking on the
option edit display name.
Type a new name, save or
hit Enter and you're done.
This change will only
occur on your class roster.
It does not appear on
the student's homepage
nor will it change the data they use
to log on to Khan Academy.
Now that you've completed
the initial setup
for your classes,
we know you'll probably
want to adjust them
in some way during the school year.
For any changes to the class,
you want to go to the settings tab.
Here you can edit the class name,
change the course or courses,
update student sync with Google Classroom,
sign up for a weekly report
on student performance,
and even delete the class.
We hope this video helps you get started
building your own classes on Khan Academy.